Two basic principles
provide the fundamental
theory behind the cloud
computing approach.
The first is the so-called
Law of Large Numbers.
This says that once you start
considering many customers
who's resources may vary over time,
the average across all of them
will tend to be fairly constant.
That's why a cloud
computing provider can pick
any amount of resources in capacity for
the cloud.
And with that capacity,
can service lots of customers,
whose peaks in the expected
demand are shifted in time.
Second, there is the Principle
of Economies of Scale.
Essentially, things
are cheaper by the dozen.
When you start considering how many
different customers a cloud provider is
able to leverage on a single
physical piece of hardware resource.
The cost of that hardware
resource ends up being amortized.
And ends up being an offset
by all of the fees
that the cloud provider is able
to gather from its customers.